good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
didn't think I could take you behind the
scenes of a deep dark place populated by
strange creatures well joke's on you
buddy because I'm back on Tumblr that's
right Hank here's the behind the scenes
of my new Tumblr sort of mine quick
backstory Tumblr is an ancient creaky
social media platform known for its uh
friendliness to Brands its abundance of
ships it's uh fondness for copy pasta I
felt very welcome on Tumblr when I
joined in 2011 and then later I felt
less welcome and then eventually left I
would say that when I left Tumblr
neither Tumblr nor I expected a reunion
but life is long if you're lucky and
full of surprises so here's what
happened a while back I decided I didn't
need a Twitter and so I turned my
Twitter into the awesome coffee club
which sends you the freshest most
delicious coffee you've ever encountered
and then donates all of its profit to
charity along with its cousin the
awesome socks Club the awesome coffee
Club is a really important part of
providing ongoing funding to fight
maternal mortality in Sierra Leone and I
just thought like I I shouldn't have a
Twitter with all these followers but the
awesome coffee Club should so I handed
the password over to longtime
nerdfighter Peyton and bid farewell to
Twitter but then I missed the social
internet partly because I missed making
low quality memes like this one about
how Twitter wasn't a bad website it was
the worst one and partly because I
missed the adventure and the adrenaline
and I guess the dread and there was
Tumblr lurking as it always is in the
shadows and so I had a long conversation
with several loved ones in which they
were like please God don't do this and
then I rejoined Tumblr but as a coffee
company I let the Tumblr algorithm pick
my new username sizzling sandwich
Perfection Dash blog and then I logged
on and much to my surprise Tumblr is
pretty fun they collectively made a
non-existent film from 1973 called
ganchirov they make a lot of art they're
still debating aspects of the television
program Supernatural it's kind of great
so anyway I entered The Fray but not as
myself as a coffee company that
definitely isn't a person oh by the way
way today the awesome coffee Club is
launching our decaf roast it's called
paradoxica which like all of our roasts
is named after a Sierra leonean
butterfly so now whether you like light
roasts medium dark roasts or decaf the
awesome coffee Club has you covered at
awesomecoffeeclub.com and that's
basically what I post about like I do
sometimes answer questions but mostly
it's memes about how I was famously
bullied off of Tumblr but have now
returned not as a human being endowed
with a soul but as a coffee company that
donates its profit to charity I no
longer want to be an individual with all
of their inherent fragility I want to be
a company which is also a person if you
ask the U.S Supreme Court I would rather
draw 25 than be a person on the internet
again I am here to drink milk and sell
coffee and I just finished my milk
anyway as I kept posting on Tumblr I
slowly began to invent the lure of
myself I started thinking about how I've
done a fair amount of work for the
awesome coffee Club but I haven't been
paid for it and that's when I realized
Hank I am the world's only ethically
sourced on unpaid intern and that is how
I am on Tumblr I am a coffee company
that is run by a person who is me who is
not being paid in any way to tell the
truth which is that the awesome coffee
Club provides amazing coffee now
including decaf to over 10 000
subscribers around the US and Canada and
then donates a hundred percent of the
profits to charity and you should join
us maybe not on Tumblr but definitely at
awesomecoffeeclub.com how is this gonna
end I mean brilliantly of course Hank
it's gonna end with kittens and rainbows
and joyous farewells just like my
previous trip to Tumblr no of course
it's going to end in catastrophe but I
can never resist the social internet
even if I know how it will end you'll
find a link in the doobly-doo to my
Tumblr and more importantly to
awesomecoffeeclub.com which makes
amazing coffee now including decaf Hank
I'll see you on Friday